presented by dr. Robin Felder professor
and associate director of clinical
chemistry and toxicology University of
Virginia School of Medicine I'm Suzy
daughter hybrids and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we're
decided to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social and networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this presentation
is interactive we want to hear from you
the questions and comments can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen monitor as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of this presentation also you're
viewing this presentation in this pod
window to enlarge that window click on
the icon at the lower right hand corner
of this live window if you cannot hear
or see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or that Q&A button and
let us know that you're having a problem
without further ado I'd like to now
present a presenter dr. Robin Felder
welcome and cell-based assays and of
course tissue engineering this work was
done in collaboration with Merck in
North Wales Pennsylvania just to test
the system we developed here at the
University of Virginia second slide
shows kind of an overview of the demand
for cell culture across all of the life
sciences in the upper left hand corner
you have cell culture of established
cell lines primary cells cancer cells
stem cells that's mostly research
laboratories performing cell culture
below that is biorepositories for cell
banking and that's important for places
like the TCC in Northern Virginia which
provides all kinds of research cells to
the research community then the upper
right there's drug discovery so you need
cell based screening and cell based
assays which are getting highly popular
and so each pharmaceutical company or
contract research organization grows
their own cells and very large
quantities to support million compounds
every week then finally therapeutics and
biomanufacturing essentially
regenerative medicine vaccine production
and whatever other kinds of therapeutic
approaches things may be useful from
cells for instance some cell products
create biologicals those biologicals can
become pharmaceuticals so that's the
therapeutic approach but the big one
that's going to dominate this entire
field is regenerative medicine because
we're all aging at a rapid pace all the
baby boomers and replacement body parts
will be necessary next slide just the
drivers for cell culture and again but
research and bio manufacturing in
research the cell based assays are
becoming more popular than enzymatic
assays let's say for drug discovery
because they want to essentially decide
on the entire cell whether the
pharmaceutical works or not and is toxic
or not certainly physiological screening
high cell based production product
production so again like the CRO s at
support pharma more valuable drug leads
which you can get there faster using
appropriately grown cells and this is
the main focus of my presentation is the
increased relevance of 3d biology over
2d biology and picture 2d cell culture
being the petri dish or the t 75 flask
and 3d biology being either a well show
that in a minute so the other area is
bio manufacturing and tissue engineering
there's increased demand for cell based
drugs and therapeutics bench lab bench
level production as a lead to scale-up
and there are very few systems currently
that scale in the 3d world from bench
level to full size production cell based
systems to replace egg-based production
of pandemic vaccines we need to get away
from the egg production because it just
takes too long and you can get the
vaccine out to market much quicker with
a cell based system particularly
automated cell based systems so the next
slide shows cell culture trends
and the trends are in all aspects of
cell culture media matrix cell lines and
so in media we're going from serum based
because all the growth factors in serum
particular fetal calf serum and then
removing to define synthetics because
there we're beginning to sort out what
those growth factors are in fetal calf
serum and we just centrally synthesized
it and put it in the media so it can be
Zeno free and you just have less chance
of raising antibodies and humans the
matrix is moving from 2d plastic to the
various kinds of 3d surfaces salt gels
hollow fiber there are a number of them
emerging and each has some strengths and
weaknesses the cell lines are going from
research-grade cells to continue to
increase use of primary cells
particularly in drug discovery and these
cells need to act as close to body
physiology as possible
also Co cultured cells where you grow
you know feeder cells and the cells of
interest and so the cells help each
other make more organs and the in vitro
organs ultimately will be able to
essentially generate hearts and livers
and kidneys and lungs should be able to
test those which are the targets of a
lot of pharmaceuticals so so basically
for cell culture is moving from basic
research high-throughput screening and
bio protection into high content
screening in other words looking for a
lot more pathways being measured at the
same time aadmi talks for you know
potentially drug therapeutics and then
regenerative medicine and cell based
diagnostics and that's that's an
interesting little point down there as a
laboratory medicine director we're just
beginning to turn the corner on using
human cells as a diagnostic tool to
determine an individual's body
physiology and that's an interesting
thing that will take cells from your
body put them in the laboratory and
we'll test what systems we think are
going wrong and the cells behaves almost
identically to how the cells and body
react to disease next slide
talking about cells as reagents because
if you look on the left side of this
slide you start with a stable cell line
then you expand it through bulk cell
culture and then you can quiet preserve
a certain amount of it for future use
and then you can re-establish those
obviously thawing them out and then
expand them again and so usually you use
them after several doublings or if you
want to save time you can essentially
try to preserve lots and lots of vials
and use use natural one doubling so that
saves you some time there but then on
the primary cell line it's pretty much
following the BOC cell culture crab
preservation and expansion but there's a
movement to dispense frozen cells
directly into an incubator and then use
them in the assay or dispense the frozen
cells right into the assay and let them
warm up and report what they want to
report so the movement is the industry
trend is towards immediate use and so
there's a lot of work going into how to
better cryopreserved cells how to better
get them from the freezer into your
assay and how to do that in an automated
fashion next slide talks about the ideal
cell culture method it should take
advantages of the new 3d paradigms
because cells grown in 3d look and
behave very much like in vivo and I'll
show you some examples of that coming up
they provide some morphology that they
make seem to be in vivo counterpart and
then physiologic and biochemical
responses are all similar and it allows
the co culture of cells for this organ
model development the assay or the cell
culture method should be automatable to
provide convenience and standardization
which are two words that are not often
associated with cell culture but that's
where we're headed we want high yield
and we want to take the art out of cell
culture so there are automated 2d cell
culture systems out on the market the
compact t the cell host the cell mate
the CJD work cell in the Sonata
all of those have seen some degree of
success and being able to do bulk cell
culture for pharmaceutical companies
they tend to be large they take up a lot
of room and they don't really perform
much more efficiently than people
because they are handling petri dishes
or tea 75 flasks just the same way a
human handles those and so there's a has
been a movement in the automated world
to try to essentially redesign a tree
engineer it for specifically for
automation and and that's what we've
done in our laboratory because we have
automated systems and we wanted to get
into 3d so we developed our own for our
NIH funded research program here and the
system has been commercialized and spun
off into the into Charlottesville so
what we have are three things that work
together a bio wiggler which is
essentially a platform on which you put
a 50 mil centrifuge tube like centrifuge
Lake tube called the leve tube and the
leve tube has little veins in it and the
wiggler does the old washing machine
motion of back and forth sort of 360
degrees in one direction and immediately
reverse to 306 degrees in the other
direction and that wiggling motion can
be essentially increased in speed
depending on the needs of the cells so
if you want to induce more stress then
you wiggle more so as we get a new term
wiggles per minute is adjustable and
then the third thing is the gem which
they name of the company was global cell
solution so Global cell it was global
cell eukaryotic micro carriers so we
thought it was a nice way to put it all
together and make it sound really
interesting so that that's again
invented at UVA to support a
cardiovascular research program so the
bench level systems on the next slide
are aimed at 3d the most popular and the
one that's been out the longest is the
wave bioreactor and that is pictured at
the upper right and what that is
essentially a gas permeable bag is
filled with media micro carriers
themselves and it rocks
just like a wave it goes left right left
right and all that sloshing gives good
oxygenation and nutrients to all the
micro carriers supporting cell growth
the cell Agentry ten from New Brunswick
is more of a bench level bioreactor
approach and that has to be taken apart
and cleaned after each event and Corning
stepped up to the plate with a
disposable spinner flask so you can
essentially put this in your incubator
and do standard impeller based cell
suspension kinds of work on micro
carriers the challenge with some of
these internal impeller based systems
are that they can beat the cells up
pretty badly and so you have to have a
fairly robust attachment of cells to
micro carriers that essentially get beat
up by the impeller so the 3d matrices
that are being used to support cell
growth are things like fiber cell iseek
iclone sphere micro carrier beads and
then side the poor for amersham and so
those three and particularly notice that
they're they're opaque so it's it's
difficult now that you can see the cells
in the high seat high q-sphere but
that's using a scanning electron
micrograph which very people who people
do routinely so if you're just taking
your representative sample out of your
bioreactor or your system and you put it
onto the scope you really can't see the
details of the cells because they're
obscured by that opaque material usually
carbohydrates are plastic so people have
been moving to other kinds of systems
mag clouds and ISA psi by well is a
various kind of more gel based systems
that give you ability to see the cells
and you can see the spherical shape and
each cell has a fluorescent signature
there so the next slide just a little
question to get you thinking about what
gaps I may have in my talk here do you
use it currently is a 3d cell culture
process in your laboratory and if the
answer is yes would be
staying to know what it is and what your
what results you're getting so next
slide advantages of 3d there are
certainly process advantages labor you
get about a 75% reduction in labor
monitoring you can actually in real time
measure cell growth and health the yield
per batch
is higher in 3d compared to 2d and you
can do continuous culture which
essentially put cells in culture and
maintain them for months if not years
under the same lineage and then the
footprint small 3d takes up less room
then standard 2d things because for
instance when we have our little I'll
show you a picture of our leve tube it's
50 mils when we only put about 40 mils
in there the mountainous cell growth you
can get in that is equivalent 75 P 75
flasks so it's essentially fill for
incubators 40 75 flasks versus just
putting cells in a 450 ml tube the
biological advantages of 3d are better
access to nutrients and oxygen because
everything's being swirled around better
morphology and physiology you can
control stress cells it's one of the
strongest cues that a cell gets is
stress kinds of cues and if you can
control that stress for instance the
Wiggles permitted in our bio levitator
then you can essentially induce
different phenotypes that are more
relevant and certainly you can put more
natural growth surfaces on into the
system so the cells are sitting down on
something that they recognize and so
they tend to say oh I'm here I'm a liver
I need to do this so the next slide
talks about the one of the biggest
problems in cell culture is that we feed
on schedule so Monday Wednesday Friday
you pull off the old media and you put
back new media sometimes you carry
forward some percentages like 20% of the
old media because it contains the growth
factors the cells have secreted but in
any case you essentially feed at Monday
Wednesday Friday and by Monday morning
the cells have been sitting quite a
while
and they're getting starving and this in
this particular slide from an Edward
Felder absolutely no relation to me but
it's I guess all the filters get into
cell culture in the world
but what glucose is the redline and its
glucose is on the x-axis I mean y-axis
left lactate is on the y-axis right and
time across the bottom and you can see
that the glucose drops to almost zero or
actually to zero until the next feeding
and then it's way up again so those
oscillations are kind of like having a
sugar fix three times a week and it
probably would lead to cellular diabetes
undoubtedly and then as the glucose is
being metabolized the cells are giving
off lactate and that gets to a fairly
high level so that up-and-down kind of
thing is not the healthiest thing for a
cell because it's not even close to what
what happens physiologically the next
slide shows actually what happens at the
cellular level to morphology so here
they what they did is a static 2d cell
culture with feed on schedule versus a
perfumed cell culture system because way
back then 2002 they didn't have 3d cell
culture technology available to them so
at the tops in the electron micrograph
it look at the upper picture and it says
you see the word basil and apical
there's an epithelial layer and you can
see that there's very few features
around where if you look at the one on
the bottom one it looks much more
relevant as a cell more circular but
notice all the little micro villi little
finger-like things sitting up there and
that's one of the challenges of 2d
biology is it doesn't the cell doesn't
know how to deploy its micro villi
appropriately and yet in 3d they can
they can do exactly what they need to do
so enhancing sub cellular structures
through a biomimetic environment is the
next slide in this talks specifically
about our 3d platform versus a
traditional 2d 2d platform so on the
left is a trans well a
when renal proximal tubular shell which
is a human kidney cell or expanding on a
filter the filter cup placed inside a
well of a micro plate so that trans well
is the trade name for that and you see
the black squarish like outline of that
cell that's those are gaps between the
cells now that's not what happens in
real life and also the cells are only
expressing 32 micro villi per square
micron then you can see little white
dots in that cell are each a micro villi
on the right that's a picture of the gem
technology and with cells growing on it
the nuclei are stained in blue with
Dappy and phalloidin stains the plasma
membrane we're currently focused on the
essentially the most proximal part of
that sphere so we're seeing the cells
that are closest to us you can see that
it buzzes out because as you because the
focus is outside a plane but what you
can do is just simply grab your focus
knob and turn it and you can optically
slice that sphere as many slices as you
want and you can see the sides of cells
and then on the far side of that sphere
you can actually see the backside of the
cell so if you'd stained with
fluorescent markers for the apical
versus basolateral side of an epithelial
so you could actually see how they
display themselves or appear on various
aspects of a cell you can't do that
anything close to that in the standard
2d world so then we did some scanning
electron micrographs and you can see 364
micro villi per square micron expressed
in these cells which is in over 10 fold
more than what happens on a trans well
and those micro villi are the
transporting members that's where all
the action is there's a in these
telltale bumps you see kind of us they
see the the cell outline then there's a
big white bump in the middle that's a
common feature of these cells in the
human body and then on right if you pull
back here your focus and don't look so
closely you can see how nicely
interdigitated those
and they're not going to be any of the
gaps between those cells like you see
over there on the Transpo on the left so
there are very apparent advantages of
moving to 3d biology for relevance and
so here's a very close-up picture on the
next slide of those microvilli and
what's an interesting feature in the
kidney is particularly in the proximal
tubules which is just after your blood
is filtered each of these cells has a
primary cilia which is those whiskers
sticking up in the media there and so as
one whisker per cell and what that is is
a bio sensor and so that cell is asking
the question okay the glomerulus has
filtered the blood what's in it and what
do I need to do if I need to reabsorb a
lot of sodium
let me sprout many more micro villi if I
want to suppress sodium because somebody
just had a triple Big Mac in Xmen of the
large fries then those primary cilia
will tell the will suppress the
production of micro villi so that whole
dynamic can't be seen in 2d in fact they
have a hard time finding acapella in 2d
but in 3d it's it's quick it's
self-evident so the challenge is
migrating to automated 3d cell culture
systems because just going from 2d to 3d
I'll warn you that it is the key cues
and the way your cells look is
completely different so you have to
relearn what to look for in your cell
culture system to determine the health
and and well-being at yourselves so just
moving from 2d to 3d it has a little bit
of a learning curve but then when we
migrate to automated systems it'll be
even more of a challenge because of all
the programming involved but you know as
with any technology it will simplify and
and there'll be a bench level automated
3d cell culture system and not so near
future so looking a little bit more
specifically at the gem technology of
the next slide the we wanted to engineer
it so it was optically clear so it
didn't interfere with any microscopy we
also engineered to be non auto
fluorescence so there's zero
fluorescence background so any questions
we're measuring is from
we head to the experimental system and
then the important thing is we added
ferromagnetic particles so the picture
little chunks of iron that are about
half the size of those little white
nuclei or bluish white nuclei in that
picture
those ferromagnetic particles there
aren't very many in the cell in a micro
carrier but they're enough that we can
take a magnet and essentially pull that
micro carrier across a slide or to the
bottom of a tune to chain facilitate
media change or just collecting the
cells for for another use and here's a
picture of the bio wiggler and I have
for the RNG I was showing you the back
and forth motion but it's 360 degrees
not 180 which is kind of pictured here
so and what's nice is you get eight
positions on the Bayeux wiggler in which
you can do independent cell cultures
each which its own controllable Wiggles
per minute so and what you can control
the volume and the tube so the point of
the bio wiggler was to make this fully
accessible to an automated system
hovering above it like a robot so the
caps would be removed the whole thing
would be in a sterile environment and
the robot could service the tubes by
sampling the media and then you could
change from feeding on schedule to
feeding on demand which is when the
glucose drops to a certain point then go
ahead and replenish the media so the
benefits of 3d are the clarity the
non-auto fluorescence its suitability
for many many cell types we have yet to
find a cell it won't grow on a micro
carrier properly engineered with a
biomimetic surface and the wiggle based
suspension is low here but you can add
more shear by increasing the wiggles per
minute but it doesn't give the cells
excellent access to nutrients and it's
suitable for automation because it's a
you can a robot can do everything
without having to move items around this
picture on the right is just a gem with
ferromagnetic particles and it was a
video that I'm having a hard time
getting
moving here but what it does is
essentially when you turn on the magnet
the term of the Jemez will slowly work
their way over to one side of the of the
vessel so the benefits of 3d cell
culture on the next slide is they're
both biochemical and morphological
attributes
there's also enhanced growth of
difficult cell lines there are a number
of cells that people find very difficult
to grow in 2d well they put them on 3d
like surfaces and they grow readily you
can do on the micro carrier treatments
so pictured are yet some forget which
kind of cell disease are but lots of
cells growing on these micro carriers
and you can elect operate those cells
directly on the micro carrier so you
don't have to trips an eyes put them in
suspension now they're very unhappy then
you elect operate them and then you hope
for the best where in this case they
tend to be a lot happier with close
neighbors and the electroporation
process doesn't cause too much damage
there's ease of dispensing them because
they could be pipetted in any standard
pipette they can be transfected directly
on the micro carrier and you can cry
preserve them directly on the micro
carrier and I'll show you some data as
to why there's some benefits there to
doing it here's the next slide the cell
culture hypoxia and in by the
biochemical effects so we start at the
bottom of the slide where I show a petri
dish and with our micro carriers in it
and we looked at micro carriers on the
bottom of the dish during their growth
phase by putting a magnet under the dish
and pulling them down to make sure they
were fairly well anchored and on the
Left we use a magnet on top of the petri
dish to pull them up to the surface
where all the oxygen was we wanted to
prove that there was really hypoxia
going on when the when these were at the
bottom of a petri dish versus there was
really good access to oxygen and when
they're all near the top of the petri
dish so the data shows that this is
relative fluorescence units on the Left
axis Ramesh
Cavill and one secretion which is a cell
membrane structural protein that will be
get secreted if the cells are having a
bad hair day like over there sorry for
the scientific jargon but the sono Maxia
you get very low amounts of C cabulance
secretion and then under high pox you
get considerably more so this led us to
believe that really hypoxia is just
standard petri dish cell culture leads
to hypoxic conditions in fact we have
poor incubators in our cell culture
laboratory and for one out of the four
was always giving us excellent cell
growth in 2d worked back in our petri
dish days and the other three were not
and we couldn't understand why one
incubator so we moved the cells around
to the different incubators and there
was always that incubator that had
really good cell growth and so little
head scratching we finally figured out
that that incubator was leaning against
the laminar flow hood and it was
vibrating so just that vibrations like
subtle vibration of the entire incubator
caused the media to stir and fed oxygen
to the cells on the bottom of the dish
and so that is kind of was one of the
kernels that made us invent this 3d cell
culture system so the effects of
nutrients and oxygen control essentially
we wanted to see how the growth rate was
in cells on a petri dish versus the
micro carrier based system and so across
the x-axis as today's and culture and B
we have a measuring cell growth here on
the on the y axis and you can see that
in the petri dish based system you get
much lower cell growth it has that
classic s-shaped growth curve where it
accelerates and it begins to accelerate
it reaches a nice slope of how fast it's
growing and then it plateaus off when
you reach confluence where as the micro
carrier-based cell culture they get a
head start they grow in a very linear
fashion because there's just no
impediments to growth and then plateaus
off obviously when the micro carriers
gets saturated all surface area sir
they're kind of
the next slide shows just a
representative number of cell lines that
we've tried out our micro carriers now
smooth muscle naturally the human
proximal tubule which is our main
research tool and the ones you might
recognize in DC kaiseki 93 sk co2 shows
on and on and on the t 2040 which is the
second one from the left in the bottom
row that's a difficult to grow cell line
and there it seemed it was very happy we
well and we did our studies with it so
other ones are smooth muscle and
rhabdomyosarcoma those are very
difficult cell lines to grow and Merck
use put their cells onto our micro
cherishment very pleased to see that
they wouldn't have any impediments to
using those cell lines in the future the
next slide shows the density analysis in
the MDC k cell line bed and RB canine
kidney cell line and what we wanted to
know is what was the cell density doing
on a micro carrier versus a petri dish
so the left column the kind of grayed
out pictures are on petri dishes on the
right are the micro carrier based growth
and you can see it give you the top row
as 10x objective and 40 x objective on
the bottom so you can see individual
cells quite readily and if you zoom in
and just randomly go through the petri
dish you see about 25 cells per unit
area where on a micro carrier you have
190 cells per unit area so then you know
the question is why is it so dense on
the micro carrier versus the plastic
well if you slice that micro carrier and
look at those cells they're growing at
very columnar shape so they dense pack
and that's exactly the way they're seen
in the kidney
so the next slide shows the density
analysis for HeLa cells and so again
micro carrier versus petri dish and
heelas you know the workhorse of the
cell culture industry and we found that
they've had about 70 cells per viewing
field on a micro carrier in about half
set and on the petri dish and again the
dense packing and the column earthing
the insects Square red square with the
little dots so we're essentially
counting nuclei per unit area so we then
want to look at the expression of a
structural protein protein so naturally
we picked villain because it's the
structural protein for microvilli if you
remember back to that scanning electron
micrograph with that field of microvilli
and the primary cilia well each one of
those micro cilia and like microtubules
Express villain in large quantity so he
did some Western analysis and on the
petri dish on the Left we had very
little villain expression and on the 3d
gem technology we had quite a bit more
said surprises that that essentially
there's that much of a difference but
our pictures bore out that that's
exactly what was going on so here's an
example of lect operation on a micro
carrier so conventionally on the right
you do so culture then you trypsin eyes
centrifuge and resuspend you wash yuri
plate you incubate and let the cells
recover and a little bit then you elect
operate them and then analyze we're in
3d we can just grow them on the micro
carriers wash them electric rate and
write on the micro carrier and analyze
so it's it is about a 75% reduction in
labor and about a 50% reduction in time
the time of just letting the cells
climate eyes is usually the longest part
of any process that's the advantage of
automating this process is that robots
don't mind waiting around for things to
happen where people are you know they
get antsy because they they know that
they could be more productive if they
didn't
to sit and watch cells recover so here's
an example of the elect paraded gems
with the GFP expression the green
fluorescence protein and the each gem is
pictured yet you have a symbol there one
gem that you can kind of get the outline
of that one micro carrier and so he was
so successfully transfected on the gems
and expressed GFP is shown in the
picture and they stayed on the gems
after the transaction and then the HeLa
gems on gems were brighter after 24
hours than those grown in traditional
culture after four days so that's like a
75% improvement in The Electrician
efficiency and so here's just some
quantitative data to show the same thing
but in this case we did T 24 difficult
to grow cell lines and there was quite
quite a bit of difference in terms of
the electroporation efficiency the
question is how well did the cells
survive following that electroporation
event which is pretty onerous for a cell
somebody's going to put it high voltage
across you and poke holes in your
membrane so they they tend not to do
well after election if we look at again
those difficult to grow lines T 24 s
we're looking at percent survival on the
y axis and in suspension which is the
traditional way of doing it we get about
25 22 and 1/2 percent survival rate
we're on t 20 24 is on gems we get
almost an 80% survival rate so we think
that clothes packing and in a digitation
of those cells protects them because
most of their surface area is spent
hanging on to each other and only one
aspect of the cell is out getting zapped
by the electric field
we also want to look at dispensing gems
into a 1536 well plate because that's
always a question a cell is about 20 to
30 microns across and they certainly a
lot of them will fit in a 1536 well but
when you now put let's say fifty to a
hundred cells on each gem how's it going
to work in a 1536 based system so here
HeLa cells were used they had we
examined six gems and they're about 750
cells per gem about 5000 cells for every
four microliters they dispensing and
this is Mark who was doing this work he
had a Calypso's instrument with a
straight tip dispenser and they were
able to dispense quite nicely so they
checked the heat map of using a cell
titer glow a say in terms of how
acceptable was the well dwell
variability and they deemed it
acceptable on the cells were cultured
for 24 hours and Patra glow confirmation
confirmation in the cells were still
viable after 24 hours so 1536 would
dramatically improve your productivity
especially if you have 3d technology in
your 1536 plate because it's more
efficient for labor and time and also
here in terms of quantity of data
producible next slide set the cells may
be easily harvested if you want to get
them off the gems and what we can do is
just use a cute ace and so you see these
gems after five minutes I still have
integrity at ten minutes upper right
they're beginning to fall apart at
fifteen minutes they're dissolving in
the twenty minutes they're gone and
because these are alginate based micro
carriers and they're held together by
calcium so if you just put an e d ta
ethylene diamine tetra stick acid like
ki later in there it'll pull out the
calcium and the polymers will just come
apart next slide shows the survival
rates which are higher on gems versus
traditional cryopreservation so again
we're starting from our normalizing to a
hundred percent of cells that we froze
down
and after cryopreservation in the petri
dish the orange bars on the Left shows
about it in let's say somewhere about
eighty percent survival rate or the safe
it's a vast reduction from hundred down
to about eighty to eighty two percent or
so but the and the micro carrier based
system you had much better recovery up
above ninety percent so apparently those
are they are the cells are protected on
that 3d environment so sorry about the
color contrast here but the HeLa cells
were checked following the freeze-thaw
cycle in a forskolin dose response essay
and here you've got relative fluorescent
units on the left and the forskolin log
concentration on the on the x axis and
you can see that of all of different
conditions frozen cells fresh cells
frozen cells on gems with 50 percent
confluence or on gems at 60 or 90
percent confluent that the SI results
were indistinguishable and not
significantly different from each other
so the so the the cells have a v'
appropriately particularly with the
force going stimulation so let's talk a
little bit about automated micro
carrier-based cell culture systems what
we in our when we invented ours we
figured we had a micro carrier we had a
levee tube and then on the right you can
see that picture of a cab row I think it
is robot servicing the the tubes and
then we have used that basis to put
together and at the lower right picture
there is our fully automated cell
culture system still of being engineered
but we're close to finished on that one
and what it'll do is you essentially
it's in an enclosed chamber with
appropriately controlled co2 humidity
and temperature but also oxygen tension
so the different cells in the body have
different requirements for oxygen
tension and very few people pay
attention to that but here we can
essentially
administer nitrogen measure oxygen and
reduce the oxygen concentration through
the administration of a nitrogen to get
to an appropriate oxygen tension for the
ideal growth of whatever so if you have
of interest this thing will have 64
independent wiggler spots so you can
grow 64 cell lines simultaneously or
random-access you know on demand and
have the robot maintain them report to
you their health or all of those or
alert you only to challenges and how
it's trying to rectify it by feeding
more or doing other changing the media
and then you know essentially you get a
little email or text message on your
cell phone and say your cells are ready
go onto the next process this robot is
capable of going on to partly on to the
next process but yes some room for
microplate so that you can actually take
the cells that are happy now put him in
the micro plates add reagents and go
from there manually but this is our
vision of the future we essentially
wanted so picture our there's our
automated cell culture system in the
middle but we want high throughput
systems screening automation connected
to the automated cell culture system so
those cells could be handed off to that
process which would proceed
automatically in the plate reading and
you just get data out to back into this
thing but it's a front-end we have
learned process of developing an
automated - 150 degree Celsius cryogenic
source
storage system which could by obey the
cells so the automated cell culture
could grow up the cells some of them
some percentage goes off for assays
immediately and a lot of it gets
cryopreserved which can happen on board
here in the automated cell culture
system and then those vials can be
handed off to the robot who would put
them away and put them in a catalogued
storage so you could have this thing
running 24 hours a day 365 days a year
generating a whole variety of assay is
only limited by your imagination
so that's the conclusion of my
presentation you ought to think about
would you consider the purchase of fully
automated cell culture system for your
laboratory and price is always the issue
the cell culture automation we're
producing is going to be about one third
the price of the standard automated
systems on the market today and the
University of Virginia is looking for an
automation partner to acquire this
technology and you know go forth and
multiply so just like cells so we won't
deal with that so here to summarize and
conclude we the desirable outcomes of 3d
cell culture is emulation in vivo
environment high cell yields from less
lab space scalable from an individual
researcher to larger scale production
significantly reduced cost consumables
eliminate contamination reduce the labor
you can easily grow difficult cell lines
automate the entire process and have
real-time monitoring with feedback
control there are issues in
transitioning from 2d to 3d you have to
as I said the beginning in my talk I
want to reiterate here you have to learn
to recognize new cell phenotypes on
these levitated beads test and use
frozen cells and assays you have to make
sure that works in your platform you
have to learn how to manipulate micro
carriers and dispensers and plate meters
and look for improved biological
responses and improve phenotypes Corning
has addressed the issue of micro
carriers in a plate because they have
these spheroid plates or they're
essentially slightly concave bottoms on
the plate and all the micro carriers
gather in the center of that well and
are more readily read by a plate reader
or seen under a microscope so I'd like
to acknowledge Marc's tremendous
assistance and showing that this
actually works in the real world not
that universities onto real world but
there's no where the rubber meets the
road is in pharmaceutical industries as
we have the group my co inventor John
Gill they
and a lot of people who spent time
perfecting this particularly Gabriel
Smith who is the main engineer of our
cell culture robot thank you so now so
now questions are coming in from the
field and so we'll see what are the
benefits of seeds 3d cell culture for
stem cells that's a good experiment or
group of experiments we did up at
Harvard and there we showed that putting
stem cells on gems maintained them in a
d differentiated State far longer than
the 2d based cell culture systems so
only until you gave them the biological
clues to differentiate would they
differentiate so at that point they
would maintain on the Deonna
on the gems now we didn't get a sense of
how long you can maintain them but we've
grown our human kidney cells and we
maintained a very stable cell culture
for nine months and just we draw out a
little bit for experiments every day so
so there is some benefit in terms of
longevity in these systems okay the next
question is is there significant cost
savings on labor with 3d I think I
answered that pretty clearly but the
significance is it's about a 75%
reduction in labor and the labor can be
less skilled because if you there's a
lot less hand manipulation which are
required skills so if you aren't doing
as much hand manipulation then you could
put less lower trained people onto a 3d
cell culture system and still have the
same degree of success sort of my cost
list on labor per per inch per
technologist another question is what
are the phenotype benefits have you seen
with the use of 3d cell culture well we
which haven't really exhausted all of
those possibilities but what we can do
is show that the cells not only look
better but they behave very close to the
in vivo counterpart we took some of the
renal proximal tubular cells grew them
on gems that
the source of the cells was not the ATCC
or a hook of human kidney which is our
normal source but the source was with
human urine and we have a clinical study
going on where we're recruiting 4000
people into a Salt controlled study
where we provide on a percent of their
consumables over a two-week period and
then they oscillate from high to low
salt or low to high salt diets and so we
wanted to ask the question how are the
kidneys performing so we do physiologic
studies but then we took these proximal
tubular cells from the urine which are
still alive we cultured them glue them
on gems and showed that their physiology
in response to sodium was identical to
the individual it came from so it's
truly personalized medicine so that's
all the I see in terms of questions at
this point I'm available see my email
address down in the lower right hand
corner feel free to email me with
additional questions or information
because I have lots of literature and
things to share thank you a webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand until August
2017 keep an eye out for an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we
encourage you to forward this
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thanks
for joining us and we hope to see you
again next time
bye-bye